eminem [ __ ] going through another
why is this kid's hat is so [ __ ] big
he looks like
yeah dude that's eminem dude no he looks
like a little kid off sandlot
the real shitty white one with the big
bill yes he's got a big
this is michael from mesa arizona he's
the voice like the state bar guys
yeah the reason that the guy doesn't
obviously this guy
is first team all [ __ ] okay
he doesn't need anything else that's why
he's not there's no
there's no jewelry there's no nose ring
there's no diplomas
this guy doesn't need dude anything he
has probably
22s with actually i bet he has rockford
fosgate 22s
in his nuts this guy
he sounds he sounds fully like satan
dude
like like if the satan could talk in
that little nazi
video it sounds like this guy dude
or sting it for you and it's
about organ donor [ __ ]
i think a guy will reach into your body
if he wants an
organ i'm gonna tell you this if this
guy
is once an organ it's gonna be more [ __ ]
bro
i am 100 certain this man has throat
cancer
for sure dude he's suffering
this guy's like he's
he's got a detachable voice box 100 dude
this guy's smart smoking marvelous who
is dead
i personally considered it but i figured
i've abused most of my organs
the last 10 15 years or so
i'll tell you stop real quick this guy's
tired because he has been basically
underground railroading his own penis
people are [ __ ]
decades they're still carrying this
thing back and forth this dude's tired
because he's on active chemo right now
he's not if you panned out dude he's
just got ivs
everywhere in a haitian wet nurse
[Laughter]
gonna be a dick move to
try and try and act like it might help
somebody so
what hold on does he want our organs
what do you want yeah what is he talking
about how many [ __ ] old black dudes
is this guy eating
i feel like everybody dude i feel like
if you [ __ ]
pat him on the back hard enough
frederick douglass will roll out of his
tongue samuel jackson is
pretty disappointing um maybe theo can
donate his
uh his sweet cheeks but uh
you know feed a family or something but
anyways
organ donor [ __ ] king of the stinging
gang
hang there
[Laughter]
he's going to be dead any day now man
that's what it is
somebody has to water his penis dude i
bet he can present i think bryan is
guilty
you don't have any [ __ ] yeah you know
how many hello tushy she's broke with
his dick
bro i bet every now and then hannah
baron just pulled his
damn face one bites bro i bet they'll
make sashimi out of this guy's
crotch when he dies dude here's what i'm
saying brother oh man i
had her i'm an organ donor my sister got
a liver when i was a kid when i was like
seven years old my sister got drinking
that early uh yeah she was drinking
yeah my mom had brad brad best milk
[Laughter]
and that's our title for the episode
brad best milk
oh i've had bread best milk and uh so
yeah my sister got that liver early dude
i used to go give speeches about organ
donation bro
yeah you know what my cousin who was at
emt
told me that if they see if you're like
dying at like a car accident and they
see organ donor they work a little less
hard
to save you because they're like oh your
body can go to science she said not
everybody but that's the thing in the
community they look at your license they
see it
they [ __ ] see organ donor check they
may just it's all
because again america's a business so is
that they might finish
get their lemonade yeah that's what it
is if they know that you want to give it
up but yeah man it's true
[Music]